-A judge ruled
that official records
from the Trump White House
could be turned over
to the congressional committee
investigating
the January 6th insurrection
and, yet, even as Trump
and his allies
face various investigations
and accusations of wrongdoing,
they're still reappearing
on right-wing media networks
to lie about everything
from the pandemic
to the economy.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
When Trump left office,
there were lots of people
I would've been happy
to never see or hear from again,
like overinflated football
Jason Miller
[ Laughter ]
or the zombie who somehow
retained the ability to talk,
Stephen Miller.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Miller ] Yes,
I did catch the rage virus,
and, yes, I do have
an appetite for brains,
but that should not distract
from the fact
that Joe Biden is
an illegitimate president!
[ Laughter ]
But, probably, the person
I miss the least is
Kellyanne Conway,
whose shamelessness
truly knew no bounds.
She was, somehow,
the Trump administration's
most prolific,
and also, worst liar.
She wasn't even smooth about it.
She lied the way your kids lie.
Did you do your homework, Teddy?
"Not only did I do
all my homework
for the entire school year
and all of everyone else's,
I also did the laundry."
[ Laughter ]
Okay, yeah.
Go do your homework.
"What gave it away?
Was it the laundry?"
[ Laughter ]
To this day, I still think
the quote that should follow her
for the rest of her career is
this moment from March of 2020,
where she insisted,
in the most condescending
way possible,
that the coronavirus outbreak
was under control.
-It is being contained and --
Do you not think it's
being contained
in this country?
-I'm not a doctor.
I'm a lawyer.
-But you said
it's not being contained, so,
are you a doctor or a lawyer
when you say it's not being
contained? That's false.
-The virus is spreading --
-You just said something
that's not true.
[ Laughter ]
-She always sounds like
she's trying to argue
that her coupon is still valid
at Talbots.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Conway ] It's valid.
Do you not think it's valid?
[ Laughter ]
You said it was not valid
and I'm just wondering
where you came up
with that it wasn't valid.
[ Laughter ]
But, hey, credit
where credit is due.
She was right.
It was all contained.
The coronavirus went away,
everything went back to normal,
I kept doing the show
in a suit and tie
in front of a live studio
audience without interruption,
and I stopped having
that weird recurring nightmare
where I was trapped in a room
with a sea captain painting
[ Laughter ]
who loved corny jokes
and sounded suspiciously
like Will Forte.
-Hey, Seth, what do you call
a painting that isn't real?
-I don't know.
-A pigment of your imagination.
[ Laughter ]
-I got to figure out a way
to get rid of that guy.
So, a deadly respiratory virus
was rapidly spreading
across the country
and, yet, Kellyanne Conway
confidently told us
everything was under control,
like a Park Slope mom
sipping a Chardonnay
while her kids
set the house on fire.
[ Laughter ]
"Don't worry.
The fire is contained
and the fumes help build up
their immune system.
Hold on one second.
Juniper!
What did I say
about adding lighter fluid?!
Juniper!
Stop squirting
the lighter fluid!
So help me God, Juniper!"
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you guys,
I'm going to let you
behind the curtain a little bit.
Wally, old Cue Card Wally,
backstage --
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, no, sure. Why not?
Wally said, "Hey,"
because, you know,
Wally's ahead of the curve...
[ Laughter ]
...so he's trying to stay
two steps ahead of it,
so we don't get in any trouble,
he goes, "Hey, you want me
to hold the cards a little off
when you're yelling at Juniper?"
I was like, "Great idea, Wally."
So I turn that way.
Wally goes that way.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, look, I get it, Wally,
you went the side
that made more sense.
-Thank you.
That's right.
Besides, you always --
-Anyway, uh,
we're talking about how
someone else is incompetent!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, yet, despite --
or, more likely, because --
of the fact that she lied
about everything,
Kellyanne Conway was invited
back on Fox News this week
to lie, yet again, this time,
about global
supply chain issues.
-You have a Biden administration
pretending they can bring us
out of a once-in-a-century
pandemic economically
and they can't admit
what inflation is.
Joe Biden telling us all
that we're sort of stupid
and don't understand what
the supply chain crisis is.
I worked at that White House
for four years.
-Well --
-We never even heard
of such a thing.
There wasn't
a supply chain crisis.
-Oh, really?
Because I seem to remember
a time when a roll
of toilet paper
had a street value just
above cocaine.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Hey, man, you, uh,
looking to score some paper?
I just got some sweet
Alabama Snowflake.
Two plys and you'll fly, baby."
[ Laughter ]
Now, in fairness,
that disruption
to the supply chain
was caused, in large part,
by panic-buying in the early
days of the pandemic,
though, I'm still not sure
why we all stocked up
on toilet paper,
like we were about to be
surprise guests on "Hot Ones."
[ Laughter ]
"Sean Evans is here!
He has 10 different sauces!
We need backup!"
[ Laughter ]
I still have PTSD
about toilet paper,
aka TPSD.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
The Sea Captain
sent that one in.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Every time I see some dude
walking down the street
carrying a six-pack of Charmin,
I scream,
"If you don't have six bathrooms
or six ass[bleep],
you better turn around right now
and take that back
to the store!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Which is a bummer
because I'm almost always
with my kids when I yell that
[ Laughter ]
and then,
they have a ton of questions.
"Uh...what's an ass[bleep]?"
Well, I guess you, if you tell
Mommy this happened again.
[ Laughter ]
It's not a threat!
It's a definition!
[ Laughter ]
I mean,
I know the last 20 months
have been kind of a haze,
but did they really
expect us all to forget
the long lines for food
and the empty store shelves
and the desperate search
for Lysol and Purell?
Do they think we've forgotten
the days
of watching "Tiger King"
and trying to make
our own hand sanitizer
out of vodka and grape jelly?
[ Laughter ]
That's not to say there aren't
supply chain issues now.
There obviously are.
I just ordered a Christmas gift
for my wife
and I got an email back
telling me
I should get it by July.
[ Laughter ]
That's just great.
Hopefully,
the cashmere sweater
will look good
on my divorce attorney.
[ Laughter ]
Happy Independence Day, Irv.
You think my wife's going
to believe me
when I say her gift
didn't arrive
because there were
supply chain issues,
especially since I've used
that excuse before?
[ Laughter ]
Even worse, I used it in 2011.
It seemed genius, at the time,
but last night, she asked,
"Hey, what was
the supply chain issue
in 2011, again?"
And the best I could come up
with was, "Um,
uh, uh, the royal wedding?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I guess like
William and Kate
bought all the bracelets
that year.
[ Laughter ]
And, in some ways, I guess
it shouldn't be a surprise
that there are
supply chain issues.
We're still living through
a once-in-a-century pandemic
that has transformed virtually
every aspect of society,
not to mention
inflationary pressures
that are,
on top of everything else,
making life difficult
for working people
in this country.
Democrats need to deal
with those issues ASAP.
Unfortunately, we got
an unhinged Republican Party
that loses its [bleep] if just
a handful of their members vote
for a bipartisan
infrastructure plan,
and millionaire
corporate Democrats,
like Joe Manchin,
standing in the way
of the agenda President Biden
promised to deliver.
And it certainly
doesn't help the optics that,
not only does Manchin have
a yacht
that he calls a houseboat,
he also apparently
has a Maserati,
as we discovered
from a recent clip
where he was confronted
by climate activists.
I'm sorry, but no politician
should have a Maserati.
Are you a senator
from West Virginia
or a plastic surgeon
from Palm Beach?
[ Laughter ]
Joe Biden drives a Stingray
and he only gets away with it
because he has the vibe
of a kind old grandpa
who's getting back into dating.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
I'm going to pick up
Nancy Pellegrino
down in the nursing home.
Oh...Nancy Pellegrino.
[ Laughter ]
I remember back in '59,
when we were
high school sweethearts.
I took her to a drive-in
to see "Ben-Hur"...
[ Laughter ]
...and we slid
into the backseat and, well,
let's just say we went at it
like Roman gladiators.
"Grandpa!"
[ Laughter ]
Cars had a lot more steel
in 'em, in those days,
and so did I.
"Grandpa, stop it!"
[ Laughter ]
The point is,
the supply chain crisis is
[ Laughter ]
very real,
but let's not act like it
just happened out of nowhere.
And the fact that the people
around Trump
are such brazen, shameless liars
is all the more reason
why we need to see actual
records of what was going on
behind the scenes
in that White House,
especially as it relates to the
insurrection on January 6th.
Trump has been trying
to keep those records hidden
from public view, but a court
just ruled against him
last night.
-Former President Trump
has lost the latest round
in his legal battle to keep
certain White House
records secret,
relating to the January 6th
attack on the U.S. Capitol.
-A federal judge has ruled
the congressional committee
investigating
the January 6th attack
on the U.S. Capitol
can access
former President Trump's
White House records.
-In this court filing,
very late at night,
the National Archives
puts out a list
of more than 700 pages,
itemized, saying,
"This is what Donald Trump
wants to keep secret,"
and they really gave details
that we didn't know.
There are these handwritten
memos, or handwritten notes,
from Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows,
specifically about January 6th.
There are call logs
and switchboard call logs
about calls to President Trump,
to Vice President Mike Pence,
leading up to about January 6th.
These are
very specific things --
White House visitor logs,
White House call records,
other memos, the daily schedule.
-I'm shocked to learn there
even was a daily schedule.
[ Laughter ]
Remember when we found out,
most days, it said...
and that was just code for Trump
not wanting
to leave his bedroom?
He'd just spend the morning
in his PJs,
calling in to "Fox & Friends,"
while viewers waited
for them to blink, to make sure
they were still alive.
[ Laughter ]
Every once in a while,
an intern would come out
and smear their eyeballs
with Vaseline.
[ Laughter ]
Brian Kilmeade always looked,
during those interviews,
like he was auditioning
to be one
of those gold statue guys
in Times Square.
[ Laughter ]
He never actually went home.
They'd just turn off the lights
and leave him there overnight.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe that's why Trump
didn't care about the pandemic.
He was the first president
to work remotely
and, even when he did
show up to the office,
I'd be shocked if there
were ever actually records
or official documents
in that White House.
You think anyone ever took notes
in a meeting with Trump?
When they finally subpoena
those notepads,
they're just going to be filled
with random doodles
and inscrutable comments,
like...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And there's no way Trump himself
ever wrote anything down.
He never even wrote any
of his own books.
They were ghostwritten, which
I'm sure Trump took literally.
[ As Trump ] I didn't write it.
A ghost did and I was
[ Laughter ]
pretty disappointed
when I met the ghost.
They said, "Donald,
we're getting you a ghostwriter
and I was hoping for a Slimer
or, even better,
a Patrick Swayze.
[ Laughter ]
That's the kind of atmosphere
the Trump inner circle fostered
and, now, it's taken hold
of virtually the entire
Republican Party.
It's a movement fully
in thrall to Trumpism,
which is why we have
to investigate what they did
and make sure
it never happens again,
especially since Trump keeps
teasing another run in 2024,
because there were times
when Trump was so abjectly,
brazenly, criminally...
-Stupid.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.